johnny réveille-toi jusque là j'ai
entendu un cri chez les voisins voici
six jeux suivants
est-ce que tout va bien je tue couvert
de cendre rentre à la maison c'est pas
mon s'en fout appelé une ambulance
immédiatement via un tube
vous avez survécu
on sort plus fort d'une telle expérience
il n'y a plus rien à craindre c'est le
dernier quart temps
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là je te jure que
je l'avais acheté quelques uns sûrement
dû se tromper
voilà il a sa place
demain soir
[Musique]
thomas
ça passe des choses que je ne peux pas
expliquer il faut consulter cadeaux je
ne pense pas que vous ayez à faire un
fantôme parfois les démons peuvent
s'attacher à des objets qu'est ce que je
dois faire protéger d'autres familles
qui es tu
[Musique]